we made this discoveries
early 1970s but it was only until 1985
that this international agreement was
agreed upon we did it and the ozone
layer is recovering this is a great
success story but it it really it stands
out for another reason
is that it's almost unique there was a
problem that society had to respond to
we decided that we had to communicate
this to society but for people in
government to respond they often need to
have public opinion in their favor it
was really not customary for scientists
to go out to try to convince the public
that something had to be done but we
realized if it is not us then who and if
it's not now when society has many
challenges today but among the most
important ones it is certainly climate
change so the problem of CFCs and the
ozone layer was entirely a problem that
was figured out by scientists and solved
by the rest of us through political work
but the issue is now as a political one
if we work together and work on all
different fronts not just you know
science and research but with politics
and economics we can have a
comprehensive solution to climate change
so we have to keep working very hard
let's be optimistic but rational if we
work together we all end up having a
better world
[Music]